but when you accept with a site called
Jew watch answer that Patrick uh Ben
David responds you sound bitter 2005 you
have to flee the country yeah a few
moments later for me for example why I
left Morocco why why why why why
you're a liar you're a liar you're a
liar to put it bluntly he is a liar it's
interesting how when a conversation is
about Islam we focus on that five
percent instead of the 95 seen firsthand
the mechanisms of an industry that
weaponizes hate now a devout Christian
convert warning the world Islam is out
to destroy you know
[Music]
that's how you recite the Quran I know
the Quran inside out this guy right here
this guy's trying to build a Dallas
engine or country I'm not telling you
right now you're a solo you're trying to
build a dawa Center here Islam is
violent by Nature assalamualaikum
brothers and sisters this is exactly why
we need the dean Center because we have
over 300 million Americans who know
nothing about Islam like this guy
yeah
in our country and Surah 9 is the most
violent chapter of the Quran the D
Center will be a source of light a mega
daoist Center an educational center
helping our brothers and sisters in
humanity truly understand Islam and
Muslims and brothers and sisters
remember the great rewards of just
guiding one person in humanity to the
truth is better than everything in this
Dunya so get in on all the rewards and
blessings click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah award
all of you
[Music]
so recently we had the discussion would
turn into a debate of the year with
Daniel and Jake and the
Two Gentlemen from the islamophobic
industry now when we say career
islamophobes this is how they bring food
to the table
so we're going to be going over bits and
pieces of the actual discussion debate
with Daniel and Jake here on the dean
show a post analysis of this event this
that happened and I wanna before they
come out we're going to get into because
Integrity is very important we need to
be honest we need to be people who speak
the truth because we follow ourselves we
follow a prophet Prophet Muhammad who is
known as
even before the Revelation came down his
Community known knew him as the most
trustworthy so that's how we have to be
as Muslims but now the people that we're
dealing with are they people who are in
this for the money as we're talking
about one of the gentlemen who was on
the program I want to have my guests
react to this we'll get into this video
and we'll get right to it wasting no
time
then I had to
um leave my family actually they
rejected me I lived as a homeless
for two years and I had to live
underground with the Moroccan Church the
converse until
2003 2005 I had to flee the Country 2005
you have to flee the country yeah a few
moments later for me for example why I
left Morocco why why why
why
I love Morocco I would love I would love
to live among my family but I left not
because of the economy I was doing well
but because I don't have freedom of
religion what
[Music]
well you're a liar you're a liar you're
a liar to put it bluntly he is a liar
peace how are you guys doing
wasted no time you guys just saw this
video what does this video highlight to
you guys what do you what do you what is
behind there's two things here one he's
talking about that he was homeless and
that's why he left and the other one he
was doing quite well what are your
comments on this uh Jake Daniel
I I don't know what to think of it other
than like the clip says it just seems
like he's lying it seems like he's got
an inconsistent story and inconsistent
narrative that he's trying to spin
um I think there's a couple other
examples that uh we could point to if we
really scrub the video as well and I
don't know what his motive is I mean we
can we can speak a bit more about what
are maybe some of the underlying motives
that he has or people like him have
um but for me I think it's very clear
he's trying to tell a sob story right on
the one hand he's trying to gain uh
emotional support from the audience when
he's talking about how he was homeless
and how he had to live like this and how
he such and such and then when it comes
to another issue where we're talking
about uh moving to uh non-muslim lands
or moving to Muslim lands he tells an
entirely different story right and so it
just seems like he's trying to create a
narrative based on the conversation to
put things in his favor
Daniel
yeah while he was crying for the two
hours I felt like handing him a tissue
like he was really seemed to be getting
out a lot of emotional uh trauma and
when you're really traumatized like our
poor uh brother Rasheed quote unquote uh
maybe your memory just goes faulty like
you can't actually
correctly recall or accurately recall
what's happened to your life were you
homeless were you doing well
sometimes trauma does that to you I
don't know
we were just talking about uh
me and Jake that some people now when
you go ahead and you give them the
correct information when you explain
things the consensus of of the scholarly
tradition what not someone might not
know but people like this what what does
it mean to be a career I mean I really
want people to understand this career
islamophobes people who make a living
off of this this is something I'm going
to read this tweet here this will kind
of push push it home and I want to
really get your guys feedback on this
this is something that
that I want really people to understand
this this is not just your average
person who might even just have a
dislike towards Islam this is people
these are people who are in the industry
this hate industry this really hit home
for me and I'll get you guys and we can
go from here having lived through this
is from a a director of he's a professor
almir colon he says having live
commenting on this having lived through
the Bosnian war I've seen firsthand the
mechanisms of an industry that
weaponizes hate exploiting fears and
divisions for its benefit the recent
debates between Muslims and Christians
challenging industry of hate that
thrives on misinformation and ensuring
fear that pads their profits Islam
encourages dialogue and emphasizes
seeking common good as mentioned in the
Quran sale people of the book come to a
common terms between us and you starting
from the belief in God to Family Values
there's a lot of stuff that you guys
talked about also uh down to the basics
of being good neighbors there is much
that we can we could be working on to
find common terms today's digital age
amplifies division divisive voices of
panic and fear genuine conversations are
powerful counterbalance to that agenda
of hate just watch how different folks
react to the call for dialogue it's
pretty revealing you can easily spot
those with a hidden agenda pushing their
narrative and stirring the pot in these
already murky Waters
go ahead Brothers take it away
yeah the islamophobia industry is
something that came out of 9 11
basically Post 9 11 you had these
zionists groups that wanted to ramp up
hatred for Muslims so that the American
and European populations would be more
and more in favor of continuous War
um in the Middle East and also this war
on quote-unquote terror around the world
so that Muslim countries would also
adopt these kinds of measures and
policies to restrict any kind of
Islamic view that contradicted
liberalism or contradicted this type of
secularism that is in favor of American
and Israeli interests basically if
Muslims organized politically and they
create
um their own States or they create you
know they they pursue or
Sharia Islamic law and their Nations
then that is going to cause a
geopolitical challenge to Israel it's
going to cause a geopolitical challenge
to Western interests capitalist
interests so it has to be stopped
ideologically and politically so you
have this quote-unquote war on terror
you want to just constantly be invading
the Middle East invading Muslim
countries and then also have the
justification for limiting uh Islamic
education attacking any kind of Muslims
over in Muslim countries who are talking
about political Islam or setting up
Islamic government or setting up you
want to basically stop that and how how
do you do it you have to have a media
strategy you have to have obviously a
political strategy you have to have this
global international law strategy but in
terms of media strategy people I like
Robert Spencer people like Pamela Geller
all these kinds of islamophobes were
propped up as quote-unquote experts in
Islam and the whole expertise is on
being able to point to the Quran and and
Hadith and Islamic texts and say see
Islam is all about terrorism Islam is
about promoting terrorism this is why
we're justified in preemptively
um monitoring surveilling detaining uh
putting on watch list putting on no-fly
lists Muslims in the west and also in
Muslim countries anyone who expresses
any kind of
um you know political Islamic idea or
ideal talks about khilafa talks about
Sharia these are terrorists they are
planning or they're they think it's uh
valid to uh do terrorism therefore we're
Justified like in terms of pre-crime
before they even do anything we're
justified in putting in place all all
these measures against them in order to
neutralize them so that's in a nutshell
what the motivation is to create this
islamophobia industry portray Muslims as
terrorists portray Muslims as these
kinds of potential terrorists who are
going to attack innocent people or
civilians or whatever and they also this
justifies liberalization of Islam we
want to liberalize Islam Muslims accept
liberal ideal secular ideals they don't
talk about Sharia we don't want them
talking about hilafa or anything like
that we want them to just be you know
liberal citizens who you know maybe
celebrate Ramadan you know just like you
have these liberal Christians or you
have liberal Jews or you have liberal
Hindus like the religion doesn't mean
anything other than celebrating certain
holidays maybe you wear ethnic clothing
and you you know eat Shawarma or samosas
that's what it means to be a Muslim
that's what they want to do for the
Muslim Community and the war on terror
and the islamophobia Machine pushes
Muslims in that direction because
Muslims are afraid to
um or their plan is for Muslims to be
afraid to express the basic tenets of
our religion and things that conflict
with the liberal overall liberal secular
worldview
here are some of those uh you mentioned
a couple of them here's um the person
that was at the debate can you guys see
this
yep and you have right next to him there
there's another individual and we just
showed this video showing what seems to
be a lie being caught out in a lie I
want I want to get into uh this person
Waleed he's also somebody who is very
active probably a friend of uh of uh
Roberts let's get into this and get your
guys reaction terrorism expert has
become a cottage industry since 9 11.
the Department of Homeland Security has
spent nearly 40 million dollars on
counterterrorism training just since
2006. DHS doesn't keep records on how
much is spent just on speakers but some
of the so-called experts who go around
the country teaching and in some cases
preaching about terrorism and the
dangers of Islam are not quite what they
seem
people it turns out like Walid Shabbat
the first thing I want to ask is what
was the purpose of your talk this
morning
to these cops and emergency responders
here in South Dakota well being a tax
terrorist myself is to understand the
mindset of the terrorist number one an
ex-terrorist it's Walid shabbat's claim
to fame a terrorist a PLO member who
bombed a branch of an Israeli Bank in
Bethlehem Square throwing a fire bomb on
the bank's roof the problem with the
story with a lot of shubat's stories
there's no evidence for them and despite
CNN's many requests neither shubat nor
his business partner have provided us
with any
bombings in Bethlehem Square you
specifically said you through the bank
wasn't but in in the Bethlehem Square
you through explosives yes I did on top
of that bank yes I did no record CNN's
Jerusalem Bureau went to Great Lengths
trying to verify shubat's story finding
the general location with a branch of
Bank Lumi once stood but not finding
anyone who could remember a bombing we
contacted the bank headquarters in Tel
Aviv asking officials to search records
no records found and Israeli police
found no record anyone ever threw a bomb
at the branch of the bank why would the
bank not have a record why would the the
Israeli police not have a record what
would the Israeli police not have a
record I don't know I mean I don't know
where you check what dates all these
things there's another part of his story
that doesn't check out shubat says he
was arrested and spent two weeks in an
Israeli prison there's no record of you
being in prison I think there'd be at
least an arrest record they held you for
two weeks
are there
okay would you be willing to do so we
did and the Israeli Detention Center
could find no record of detaining anyone
with the name Waleed shubat yeah I mean
you obviously can see why people are
critical of of your claims there's a
whole lot of gaps in your story there's
no gaps we don't have a bank bombing and
we don't have a terrorist because it
turns out Walid Shabbat even on his own
admission was never charged
I was in prison for a few weeks what was
I in charge no I was U.S citizen
remember I was born by an American
mother the other uh conspirators in the
ACT ended up in jail I ended up being
released there's another problem his
family in the neighborhood where Walid
Shabbat grew up relatives say he was
just a regular kid and dawood shubat who
says he is walid's fourth cousin goes
even further because
there were only two banks in Bethlehem
district and they are bank leomy and
discount bank they were on Nativity
square and valid never had any
connection with those two Banks not a
close or a distant connection I tell you
this is out of experience I am one of
the people who are considered a
responsible man in the area of Bethlehem
or better I've never heard anything
about Walid being a mujahid or a
terrorist
he claims this for his own personal
reasons so we can see a pattern that
just like the first guy here he's making
certain claims and then getting caught
out slowly I'm sure if you dig if you go
deeper you're going to find more lies
and this is one of uh the people in that
same network being called out who's
actually out there he's in front of
these agencies saying that all Muslim
organizations need to be investigated
portrays himself as a man converted and
on a mission once a Jew hating bomb
throwing terrorist now a devout
Christian convert warning the world
Islam is out to destroy you
[Music]
that's how you recite the Quran I know
the Quran inside out
English and if you meet the unbelievers
then Smite off their necks
what part of smite off their necks
do you Americans don't understand his
message before a largely positive crowd
of cops and emergency responders at this
South Dakota Homeland Security
conference trust no muslim especially
those who organize no you're enemy
know your enemy
all islamist organizations in America
should be the number one enemy all of
them the islamist organization Islam
Society North America should be focused
on you got that on camera yes please
he is being paid five thousand dollars
plus expenses to speak here with your
tax dollars he was also given a Rapid
City police guard during his time in the
city all Muslims you can't trust them
and he's preaching the same thing like
uh the person that you guys were
debating he's saying the same exact
thing and he gets caught out as a liar
pretty much it just ends his career but
where are the people vetting these
so-called terrorism experts that are
suddenly making a lot of money in this
country
what are you guys thoughts
yeah I mean I would say I think it's par
for the course right with these kind of
people uh they're not trustworthy we
can't we can't trust them at all uh we
see time and time again that they get
caught up in lies and I was mentioning
uh one example of that
um earlier actually to Eddie uh during
the discussion which I actually didn't
notice I'm not sure if Daniel noticed it
or not uh when uh so-called brother
Rasheed was trying to bring up an
example when I was speaking about the
violence uh in war and the killing of
infants uh being targeted in war in the
Old Testament in first Samuel 15 uh and
I I made the claim that you find no such
um assertions or commands from God or
the prophet uh peace be upon them in the
Quran or Sunnah and he laughed and he
said oh it's not in the Sunnah and then
he tried to bring a Hadith uh where he
was claiming that you could find that
but if you go back to the tape and watch
when they actually read it the Robert
Spencer actually read The Heading of the
Hadith in which it said uh something to
the effect of killing these people
unintentionally not intentionally so the
the reason why I bring that up is
because it's not as if they weren't
aware of that it's not as if if they're
not aware of the other Hadith that
explicitly teach that you are not
allowed to kill non-combatants uh women
and children and infants
during war they are aware of it and
they've probably been corrected about it
before but yet they continue to lie
about these things because as you're
mentioning Eddie they get paid they get
funded by these different organizations
and they make money off these uh
speaking events and different venues
that they attend and that's why they
need the lies to continue so even when
they're corrected and even when after
this video comes out and they're
corrected again they will continue to
make the same assertions and the same
lies about Islam and what Islam teaches
Daniel
yeah I mean they have no shame like
what kind of Ethics do these people have
like it doesn't seem that they're real
Christians
they don't you know are they atheists I
mean this is one of the things that
people have brought up with Rasheed you
know one of those guys is is he really a
Christian like
um Jake asked him like what church do
you go to and he seemed like he was a
deer caught in headlights uh Rasheed I
know that Robert here is uh Eastern
Orthodoxy he used to be Catholic uh what
denomination or sect of Christianity do
you belong to because we are Converse in
Morocco we don't follow anything we just
follow I'm saying like do you go to a
specific church I meant went to many
Orthodox Protestant I don't care okay
she didn't really have a straight answer
like Christians go to church like
regularly they're supposed to
um practicing Christians they go to One
Church
um for an extended period of time if
they move maybe they'll go to another
church but they have they're associated
with a church he couldn't give an answer
to that and people were saying is this
guy really Christian maybe he's an
eighth atheist so what kind of Ethics do
they have like I know Christian people
and usually they won't just lie to your
face like blatant lie
so yeah maybe that's the source of their
creativity with the truth is that they
don't have any kind of principle of
honesty or truthfulness or
trustworthiness that they abide by
that's probably the best explanation and
if you can get paid to lie then
nothing's holding you back they just go
for it
we had some recent developments also of
one of the panelists insulting coming
out insulting Patrick Patrick who did a
great job he was very you guys also feel
as myself he was very fair and balanced
he did a great job
and then we have this coming up what are
your guys thoughts and uh Patrick uh Ben
David responds you sound bitter after he
was insulted you sound bitter and
frustrated you were given an opportunity
to come and discuss the difference
visits between Islam and Christianity
they seem prepared with pointed
questions to ask you while you seem
defensive being upset with your
performance is understandable
yeah I mean listen
um
Robert was completely out of line
um initially and I checked his Twitter
account he seemed to be fairly quiet on
Friday but for whatever reason I don't
know I guess he woke up on the wrong
side of the bed on Saturday or maybe he
finally came to the realization that he
did terribly in the discussion and that
many Christians even uh were coming to
inform him of that that he started
attacking various people not only
Patrick but chose to sort of at random
uh attack Patrick it was totally
uncalled for of course we from the
Muslim side do not support Robert doing
that whatsoever as we said numerous
times and we'll say it again here uh
although Patrick is a Christian and he
may have certain biases he did not
display them at all during the
discussion he invited two Muslims and
two Christians to a large platform arm
gave everyone an equal opportunity to
speak and share their ideas no matter if
he agreed with them or not I'm sure he
didn't agree with any of the four of us
a hundred percent but he allowed
everyone equal opportunity to speak and
for Robert to have a complete meltdown
like a baby like a sore loser on Twitter
and come out and attack the Christian
host who invited you to a large platform
to share your ideas even if he doesn't
agree with everything that you have to
say and remained fair and balanced all
throughout the discussion for you then
to publicly attack him without just
cause without justification whatsoever
is completely ridiculous and it makes
him look worse than he already had
before that I mean he should have just
taken the L he should have just taken
the loss taken his ball and went home
and you know just cried in his own home
but instead he had to go to Twitter and
start attacking people that shouldn't
have been attacked and Patrick's
response I mean you know shout out to
him it was perfect right he said look if
I were you with that performance I would
be frustrated right I would be
disappointed this is basically what he's
telling him and he hadn't voiced that
that clearly before but since you
attacked him he lets you know hey look
this is exactly what it is I gave you an
opportunity to come on you dropped the
ball that's your problem don't blame me
uh before we go into this next clip I
want to make just something I'll point
something else as I open up the program
I I spoke about the character of prophet
Muhammad peace and be upon the last and
final messenger sent to mankind uh his
trustworthiness known as
there is this this constant attack that
they put out there this term Takia
and we know this is something that is
not a part of the the Muslim Community
this is a sect of Shiite who use this
term uh and this is not something that
Muslims uh to try to persuade someone to
come to their religion they're going to
use deceptive uh lie lying what are your
guys uh because then you get to a you
get to a place where how can you develop
trust when you constantly they put this
in the back of your head like these guys
are just lying to me uh if this I don't
think this came up during the discussion
but it's something that's very important
might be many people maybe some
Christians out there they've heard this
repeated I wanted to panel this over and
over and over how do you like to address
this Daniel
address the line the term yeah yeah you
can't trust these Muslims you know just
lying to you they're Liars
I mean this
how could we be Liars when we told them
exactly what they asked us
they they asked us about violence they
asked us about certain punishments and
laws and we explained them you know we
didn't deny those certain accusations
that they made about Islam what their
law what who's the actual Liars in the
conversation are them they're doing the
actual Tapia because they
um you know we can ask them about the
Bible we can ask them about Christian
history we can ask them about their
Church you know the Orthodox church and
what the Orthodox Church is doing
um in different parts of the world
um or what the Orthodox Church is doing
in supporting Russia in its ongoing
engagement in Eastern Europe we asked we
asked them about all those things they
were less than forthcoming they were
less than forthright in giving us
answers and it was it came across
clearly to the audience both Muslim
Christian non-muslim that these guys are
hiding something these guys don't want
to give a straight answer they're just
dancing around the issue and not giving
a straight answer so that's that's Tatia
and they're they're the ones who are
doing tahria they're hiding their
liberal secular even atheistic
Tendencies and pretending to be
something that they're not which are
which is Christian
with this uh because you're an expert
there in the the Bible you come from a
background former Christian uh Jake tell
me we don't have anything obviously
there is there is there are some uh
there are some exceptions uh and many
know this when you're trying to
reconcile between people to family
members you're allowed to go ahead and
you know to bring them together
um you're you're allowed to
um uh when your wife cooks you a good
meal or and you don't like maybe she put
too much salt in it you're like yeah it
was great baby it was uh wonderful but
you're actually not telling the truth uh
when the Muslims uh when the Jews were
coming over
um and they were being persecuted by by
the Christians actually then the Muslims
were hiding them in Albania and Bosnia
and in Turkey many places all over the
world they were actually when they would
come knock on the door and say do you
have any Jews here and I'm just like no
to save their lives so this was
something allowed but
um Jake when you see this here would
this constitute something what they're
trying to say and I just hate doing this
I don't want to offend any Christians or
anybody but you know when these people
throw stones out of a glass house how
would this be interpreted here well how
do what's the proper interpretation of
this yeah for the truth of God hath more
abounded through my lie onto his glory
why am I also judged as a sinner and
then Paul is asking this question sort
of rhetorically he's he's it seems like
he's saying well it's it's okay uh to
lie in order to uh win over Sinners
what's the problem because you're you're
achieving a greater good and there's
also another text uh Eddie which is in
First Corinthians chapter 9 verse 20
which says and this is Paul against
supposedly speaking to the Jews I became
like a Jew to win the Jews to those
under the law I became like one under
the law though I myself am not under the
law law to win those under the law to
those without the law I became like one
without the law though I am not outside
the law of God but I am under the law of
Christ to win those without the law so
basically you know he's saying to the
Jew he acts like a Jew like he's he acts
as if he is under the law with the Jew
and then with the Gentiles well he's not
really under the law so he he acts as if
he's not really under the law right so I
mean really and I think what Eddie is
trying to highlight here is that at the
very least if the Christians want to
play the game of Takia and that Muslims
are liars and you know we're just
misrepresenting our own religion to take
advantage of people and intellectually
manipulate people all of that first of
all is false uh we have the Hadith which
uh Eddie was referencing about the
situations in which you can lie right to
reconcile between Believers to espouse
in the case of what you've mentioned
right or uh if it's it's specifically in
the case of warfare right and
um those are the only exceptions then we
have all sorts of other prohibitions
about lying and about the position of
the liar in the religion it's not a good
position for a liar trust me but if you
want to as you said you want to throw
rocks from a glass house
well we can go to text like First
Corinthians 9 to the Jew Paul acts like
a Jew well then when he's with the
Gentile he's acting like the Gentiles
he's is he under the law or is he not
under the law right and this was a big
controversy in early Christianity so
um like you said if they want to play
that game right you know we can quote
these verses and say look if anything
Paul and what you find in the New
Testament you guys have a problem with
this concept of Tapia not us
yeah and only bring this out to to point
out the inconsistency and to point out
you know these double standards and to
point out you know the hypocrisy is
clearly and um so hopefully people can
see this and they cannot get uh Swept
Away with many of their this empty
rhetoric that they put our spells out
there let me go into the next clip you
want to grow your numbers and the grow
the Christian population I want to help
Christians grow because I think a world
that has more Christians is better than
a world that has more atheists but how
can you have more Christians when you
don't really believe in the Bible we
have the seeds of the destruction of
Christianity right in this podcast
because when you look at the way that
Robert and Rasheed describe the Bible
they describe it as a book of fables and
it can continue to evolve I didn't say
that this is going to this is going to
cause apostasy this is going to cause a
decrease in faith like why should I take
Christianity seriously when it just
evolves and it changes over time I can't
connect my practices and my beliefs as a
Christian today with the historical
Jesus so why am I going to maintain
myself as a Christian and then also the
the whole theology which we haven't
discussed at all today like the 95
monotheism is uh 80 to 90 of the world
believes in monotheism in one God and
monotheism is a central crucial the most
important part of Islam the belief in
one God Without Partners he is not like
anything this is a very powerful belief
that 80 to 90 percent of human beings
profess in this day and age and Islam
represents that in its Theology and
emphasizes that in its theology but if
you have a trinity or you have a
theology that is not really clear as
Jesus God is there a godhead is there
this other system do we go by the
Catholics or do we go by the Orthodox do
we go by the Protestants you don't have
a consistent Theology sunnis and shias
they all agree on the on monotheism God
is one he is not like anything they
agree on the Quran yeah there can be
some theological differences and nuances
between different schools but there's
not the same kind of disparity or
variance between Christian sects and
this idea of the Trinity which frankly
no one can understand like what does it
mean to be three in one
so some have called both of you guys The
Defenders uh especially Daniel with this
statement Defenders of uh Christian
traditionalism I think many Christians
out there they they were respecting this
this position here and they were
actually what we were seeing were you
guys seeing the same thing that many
Christians were very appalled at the
direction they were going they were
pretty much throwing the Bible under the
bus and some people would say actually
these things never happened at all that
they were uh they were they were fables
what do you guys uh
what do you guys think yeah I think that
they were surprisingly uh
non-reverential and non-disrespectful to
the Bible
um it seems like the Bible is not a part
of their lives they don't take the Bible
very seriously uh Robert didn't really
ha seem to have much respect for the
Bible because he was talking about it in
this very disrespectful way and and a
lot of the Christian viewers that might
have reached out to Eddie or they were
commenting online said that they were
very offended they were offended and
shocked and they said that this person
does not represent our religion he does
not represent a true Christian
so I think that's a fair critique of
Robert but our whole strategy with me
and Jake is we wanted to bring that out
we wanted to bring out through the
things that we were asking and through
the way that we were addressing their
challenges to Islam we wanted to bring
out their hypocrisy and lay it bare for
the world to see that these islamophobes
are just liberal secularists they're not
actually traditional Christians if they
were traditional Christians they could
bring arguments against Islam from the
Bible they could bring arguments against
Islam from the church tradition perhaps
maybe they could bring in those kinds of
arguments and we could have a nice
discussion about the nature of the
Trinity versus torhead like that kind of
uh theological debate or discussion
instead they're bringing arguments from
atheists they're bringing arguments from
Liberal secularism oh Islam is violent
Islam does not respect uh freedom of
religion freedom of speech and so forth
so this this exposes their hypocrisy and
it makes it very easy for me and Jake to
just knock all of their arguments down
because that's exactly what we had
anticipated right and that yeah just to
add one thing there
um which is which is important and it's
related to Patrick that David the host's
goals which is Building Bridges I mean
they want to talk about they can't build
Bridges with us for for their reasons
but their reasons are based on as Daniel
was saying secular liberal values
um the problem that we have with them
and why it's difficult to build bridges
in the sense with those not Christians
in general but with those two specific
individuals is because it's almost as if
we have to teach them what their own
Bible and what their own tradition
teaches then get them to accept it and
see that that's actually more in line
with what the Quran and the Islamic
tradition teach right so it's almost
like we have to teach them their
religion first so that they can actually
see
what the uh commonalities we have
between traditional Christianity and
traditional Islam but these two guys
unfortunately either they're just
completely ignorant of their own uh
tradition and uh Bible their own
scriptures or their dishonest and or
maybe a combination of both but
unfortunately with them the difficulty
we had is we kind of have to teach them
what they should believe based on what
their texts and what their own tradition
says as opposed to these uh secular
liberal values that they're coming to
the table with because of course no we
CA we're not in line with them Islam
will never be in line with them and
we're not going to compromise on those
things so we're trying to show them from
their own scripture and their own
tradition right that it's actually more
in line with the traditional Islamic
values he's been cited by terrorists
Defenders brevik okay about 100 people
in Norway Robert Spencer said read
everything from Robert Spencer about
Islam
who keeps multiplying those things and
so you have to allow for some time would
you accept with a site called Jew watch
answer that so if the site has first of
all profiles on
pretty much every speaker like every
American Muslim speaker I think is
featured so his claim that oh we only
monitor terrorists
how are how how am I a terrorist for
example do I have I committed any kind
of terroristic act or advocated any kind
of terroristic act no I denounced
terrorism but I'm featured on your site
so what exactly is the criminal activity
that
um you know makes me deserve to be on
his site
um other speakers who have condemned
terrorism they're very mainstream
speakers I completely disagree with
they're featured on on the site as well
they're like as far away from terrorism
or criminality as you can possibly be
Robert Spencer portrays them as
terrorists or potential terrorists on
his Jihad watch so this is a complete
lie he is really a sleazy human being
um excuse for a human being and I gave
examples of how he will have reports on
his site of just someone with a middle
eastern name who doesn't hasn't declared
Jihad hasn't declared any kind of
allegiance to Islam but oh it goes on
Jihad watch because this is a middle
eastern name who has committed some
crime some violent crime therefore he
must be a Jihadi like this is such clear
racism such clear bigotry and he he's a
sleaze back I don't know how else to say
it like you uh to sit there in that
podcast and lie to our faces and lie to
the audience like because at one point
he was saying that oh yeah it's really
unfortunate what happened with this
counter terrorism efforts or the war on
terror Etc and to pretend like he was
against the invasion of Iraq and
Afghanistan and like he was just
whitewashing his entire history and
alhamdulillah you know we got an
opportunity to point out his lies but
really just so Shameless I'm glad that
his career is is pretty much wrapping up
now because of this uh backlash from his
terrible performance you may mentioned
also there in the discussion that there
was a report of someone who came out and
they said it was a Muslim who did some
some uh some crimes and and it ended up
being someone out it wasn't a Muslim he
just put put because he hadn't he had um
he was uh an immigrant can you talk
about that yeah there's a Syrian
immigrant in France who started stabbing
people at a playground in France and the
news reports came out and immediately
Spencer puts out a tweet saying oh
um Jihad you know this is a Jihadi
killing children at a playground I don't
remember the exact wording but I can
send you the tweets if you want to look
at it more closely but he says like oh
this is a Muslim then uh in a few hours
later the reports in the news were
saying that this is Abdul masir that's
the name of the guy Abdul masi he's a
Christian
you know slave of the Messiah that's the
translation of abdom he's Syrian but
he's a Syrian Christian not a Syrian
Muslim so then Spencer put out a partial
retraction saying okay it seems like
this is a Christian but then he doubled
down and he put out another tweet and
another Jihad watch article saying oh
actually this was a Muslim this was a
Muslim based on what because all of the
news reports from the BBC from France 24
from even CNN I think uh we're saying No
this is a Christian Syrian immigrant
so what how on what basis is Spencer and
Jihad watch saying that this is a Muslim
you go to the article and the article
just has one source it's a French blog
that is like just a random blog that
says oh we contacted the cousin there's
there was a cousin of this Abdul masi
who says no actually this he's a Muslim
he's not a Christian it's just like
based on some random person unknown
person's testimony that oh he's actually
a Muslim so on that basis Jihad watch
says no we were right the first time
this is actually a Muslim uh terrorist
immigrant who's stabbing little children
like that's the level of hatred that
they have for Muslims that they will
defy all kinds of journalistic standards
all kinds of standards of honesty and
decency they'll even go against the
mainstream media just so that they can
put out this message that Muslims are
terrorists most Muslims are bloodthirsty
Killers even when there are clear
examples that go contrary to their
narrative so how about what did you mean
when he said okay uh if you had a site
called Jew watch or black watch or
yeah I mean what so imagine like any
Jewish person commits a crime and we say
oh this is a crime from Jews this
represents the Bible this represents the
talmud because in the Bible there is a
there is violence in the Bible you know
we read the passages or there are verses
that say uh this or that that seem to
endorse criminal Behavior violent
Behavior therefore this is biblical
violence this is judaic violence and any
Jew that commits a crime
um any kind of criminal activity we will
pin that on Judaism and therefore we
call it Jew watch or we'll call it
judaic watch or we'll we'll talk we'll
call it Torah watch or something of that
nature uh which would Spencer agree with
that kind of uh site you know he says
the ADL with the ADL or any of these
organizations allow that do you think if
there was a site like that people to
come out and and blatantly you know
allow these people to come out and have
a platform and whatnot I think it'd be a
different story it's just uh pointing
out the the double standards and clear
hypocrisy here now yeah I mean I think
it's pretty blatant
um nothing like he his sight and and his
tweets when he posts oh a Muslim Jihadi
did this where's the proof that this
person is actually a practicing
believing Muslim is it just based on the
name
um in most of the cases there's not a
Manifesto or there's nothing that
Spencer is so unhinged and detached from
reality that in one um discussion that
he had he claims that since 9 11 there
has there have been forty thousand
Jihadi attacks
in the world forty thousand since nine
eleven so maybe if you are a bigot or
you're stupid that sounds plausible 40
oh wow 40 000 since nine eleven it's
it's been 22 years so I guess that's
possible but then you do the math and
then you realize that well since 9 11
there's only 8 000 days that have passed
since 9 11 22 years ago 8 000 days
divided by 40 or 40 000 divided by 8 000
that means there's five Jihadi attacks
every single day continuously since 9 11
like that's what uh is implied on
average there are five Jihadi attacks so
this is just some made up stats made up
numbers made up you know terrorists
anyone who has a foreign name oh this
must be a Jihadi militant uh he's
probably counting the guy who was on the
CNN he's did a lot of them also
exactly at least 20
yeah but there's also something else uh
Daniel that that I would like to comment
um
as you mentioned in part of the
discussion you brought up his articles
that he's written on you the these these
four articles that he has on his website
and and you you can confirm because this
happened and you guys didn't see it live
on air but immediately after we we went
live uh or we we were off the the
program uh Robert Spencer
admitted that he had not even read the
articles right and yet he was trying to
convince Daniel and the audience that oh
everything in the articles that is there
that I've said about Daniel or that is
written on the side about Daniel is true
and there's no question about it and
blah blah blah blah but then later
's off he admits that he hasn't even
read the articles right so how is that
the case that he knows everything in
there is true he hasn't even read it
well that just goes again to his
dishonesty he's not honest at all he has
no Integrity whatsoever and even double
down on it well yeah even though I
didn't read it I'm sure it's 100 True on
you anyway so this is the kind of person
this is a kind of slime ball that we are
dealing with people here and I don't
think people really fully realize that
that this man has no problem lying
straight to your face no I don't think
it is so is it inherently immoral yes or
no can I yes or that it is it is so when
the Bible when Deuteronomy since you
like to quote the Quran when the Bible
says this in Deuteronomy 13 6 if your
brother the son of your mother your son
of or your son of your daughter the wife
of your bosom or your friend who as as
your own soul secretly entices you
saying quote let us go and serve other
gods which you have not known neither
you nor your are fathers of the Gods of
the people which are all around you near
to you or far from you from one end of
the Earth to the other end of the Earth
You shall not consent to him or listen
to him nor shall your eye pity him nor
shall you spare him or conceal him but
you shall surely kill him your hand
shall be first against him to to put him
to death and afterward the hand of all
the people and you shall Stone him with
stones until he dies because he sought
to entice you away from the Lord your
God who brought you out of the land of
Egypt from the house of bondage so all
Israel shall hear and fear and not again
do such wickedness as this among you so
when let me let me finish
so when you're loving God Jesus Christ
who you believe is God who revealed the
Old Testament and revealed this as a law
for the people and you said that it's
inherently immoral for the punishment of
apostasy to to be death then you are
charging your own God and supposedly
loving Jesus with immorality not at all
if you don't see that contradiction and
hypocrisy really do much for you well
it's not in the least contradictory or
hypocritical because that is God
actually
ordering something directly wrong for
that now the question here the point for
the audience uh the point that you were
trying to drive home can you go ahead
and explain that yeah the point I was
trying to drive home is that people like
Robert Spencer and Rasheed and some some
of these other islamophobes they try to
say that Islam is false or Islam is
invalidated in virtue of these supposed
uh violent themes that you can find in
Islamic Doctrine with Jihad or with the
concept of capital punishment for
certain crimes because Islam has those
doctrines and those uh laws and and
legislation these punishments that seem
harsh that's immoral and wrong and
because of that right that means that
Islam is false it's invalidating people
should not follow Islam people should
not be Muslim and what I'm trying to
point out is if your argument is true if
you were consistent then you would have
to reject Christianity and Judaism for
the same reason but because you don't
that shows that you're a hypocrite and
one of two things either you're just
doing this to you know cast doubt on
Islam and try to condemn Muslims right
in a dishonest fashion or you don't
actually believe in your own Bible you
don't actually believe in your own
scripture and tradition and therefore in
what sense are you even defending
Christianity or Judaism for that matter
you're not at all in fact you're more
like a liberal secularist and that's why
Robert and other Christians like this
guy inspiring philosophy that Daniel
also debated they're just liberals right
they're just clear liberals and what
they do is they say oh well this is just
poetic language in the Old Testament
these weren't really commands for the
people this was just poetic language
these are just stories or fables that
are meant to you know present us with
certain um lessons that we can learn
from these stories but maybe they didn't
even happen and their historicity is in
question we're not really sure if they
happened or maybe they killed a couple
of people but they didn't kill any
infants this is what they're trying to
say and it's just a lie right if you go
go to their actual uh Church fathers and
how they interpreted these texts and how
they these texts were interpreted by uh
popes for example used to sanction uh
Warfare against uh Muslims or what they
called the saracens at the time uh it's
it's very clear that that's the case and
they're just totally opposed to it so
they have one of two things either they
can throw their Bible under the bus
which they did or they can stop using
these terrible arguments against Islam
and let's get to the real issues let's
debate over whether Christianity or
Islam is true and based on fundamental
principles like tawheed and all of the
other things that we would like the
opportunity to speak more about in the
future inshallah just say to them what's
your response to them
yeah so just to a few points here number
one it's interesting how we want to talk
about Islam as a religion but we the
religion is 95 like what Jake mentioned
it's about worshiping God being devoted
to a righteous way of life loving your
neighbors taking care of your parents
that's what 95 of Islam is about yes
there are criminal punishments which
we're going to discuss there is
um Conquest there is war Theory there's
all of this in Islam but it's
interesting how when a conversation is
about Islam we focus on that five
percent instead of the 95 of what Islam
is about we don't see this kind of
double standard with like Christians so
if you have someone like Matt Walsh Matt
Walsh is a traditional Christian there's
slavery in the Bible there's punishment
for blasphemers in the Bible there's
killing of Heretics and the church
tradition there's no discussion of that
with Matt Walsh right or Ben Shapiro
there is killing of blasphemers in the
Hebrew Bible there is you know
punishments for apostasy in the talmud
there's no discussion of that with Ben
Shapiro you can talk about you know
other values and that's what the
discussion focuses on but the
islamophobic narrative is just blazering
in on these specific topics which is
fine we can discuss that but I just want
to note the double standard so the other
framing of this whole discussion that I
want to put out here though this is a
very important point that I want the
audience to understand what you just
said lasering in
on this two three percent the penal code
of Islam and forgetting about everything
else the worship of one and only one God
the creator of the heavens and earth
being morally upright being good being a
good son a father a mother giving in
charity prayer fasting all of the things
that are out there that we can agree on
you know Traditional Values of
Christianity also has much of this and
you hit this home that they they throw
the stones out of a glass house and I
want you to go ahead and and uh what you
were Daniel when you were saying they
laser in on this they laser in on this
and they put this under a microscope
isn't this just clear hypocrisy
yeah I mean when was the last time you
saw uh Matt Walsh go on to a podcast or
Candace Owens go on to a podcast they
are known to be traditional Christians
you know they care about the Bible like
that's their whole brand as traditional
Christians when they go on to you know
speak on news outlets or go on other
podcasts for interviews it's not really
a discussion about the Bible it's not
really okay justify why we find these
things in your belief system that you
profess in your church tradition of
which you follow they're not really
interrogated about that but Muslims if a
traditional Muslim like me or Jake or
Eddie we go on to any kind of mainstream
platform uh these are the things that
are definitely going to come up you know
what about the age of Aisha radial when
she married the prophet sallallahu
alaihi sallam are you in favor of quote
unquote child marriage are you in favor
favor of blasphemy punishments these are
the things that are focused on why or in
participation of the hand for example
for theft these are the things that they
focus on why because they want to
exclude traditional Muslims from the
discussion from the mainstream
discussion the only kind of Muslims that
are accepted on these mainstream
platforms there's only two kinds one are
the unhinged criminal terroristic
um crazy types those will be featured on
the news those will be featured in
interviews those will be featured in the
movies right or the TV shows or the
leftist
pro-lgbt feminist Muslim that drinks and
alcohol and smokes weed that type of
Muslim those are the who doesn't really
you know take Islam seriously those are
the only types of Muslims that are
allowed to be featured on the mainstream
in the west and and increasingly in the
East you know and some of these Muslim
countries as well there are TV stations
are controlled by Western powers or
Western influence they also will not
show you know a traditional Muslim who's
intelligent who can speak on relevant
issues that can give a coherent
compelling Islamic message they're
excluded from the TV cameras the news
channels from the podcast this is
deliberate like in some of these Muslim
countries they will bring like a Sheikh
or a scholar to represent the Islamic
View and that Sheikh will just be a
complete idiot or will just be vulgar or
we'll talk in a way that is you can say
is so stupid because they want stupidity
and vulgarity and all and Insanity
craziness to be associated with Islam
and traditional Islam that's this is a
deliberate agenda and we have to call it
out and I'm going to show this image now
and this is not uh as a joke this is
just to hit the hit this point home
imagine if Kansas Owens came on like you
just said came on to a platform and they
started to pick random verses from the
Bible and played this game and I'm just
gonna show this image so it can hit home
so they can see the hypocrisy so
hopefully this can stop this game this
Evil game can stop so imagine now
because you mentioned this uh the
amputation of the hand for the thief so
imagine someone went in the Bible and
they drilled Candace Owens and there's
other verses you know that are out there
about uh where Jesus is talking about
the person who insults his mother or
father
like imagine okay Jesus said and the one
who break the command for God for the
sake of tradition for God said honor
your father and mother and anyone who
curses their father mother shall be put
to death I mean this is Jesus who we
love and reverse one of the mightiest
messages imagine that or imagine someone
came now to caniso and says how do you
explain this you know when two men are
fighting and the wife of one of the men
rescues her husband so Candace Owens
imagine you're rescuing your husband
from a thief who just broken your host
someone from this woke movement they
broke in and they you grab them by the
and then uh this is kind of disturbing
even to look at this but now if you end
up cutting off his uh if she she's the
one who's supposed to get her hand cut
off for saving her husband you guys get
the point
yeah of course I mean it's just
ridiculous it's hypocrisy and that's
what we basically been saying the whole
time Sharia is to be applied everywhere
every time and that's the biggest
difference with Christianity because
Jesus came and he stopped the Old
Testament what are you guys comments I
mean often when I think of sharia people
think the boogeyman's coming to get you
not knowing that the Ten Commandments uh
correct me if I'm wrong uh ten commands
is Sharia you know in the Arabic Bible
over 200 times Sharia this is God's law
this is there so they you know and he
should know that he's an Arabic speaking
person and he's mentioning the term
Sharia like it's something foreign to
him uh this term what do you guys think
when uh when when you when you hear that
yeah it's shocking like this is a kind
of um there was a sect within early
Christianity
um the marcianites you know the
marcianites believe that the Old
Testament
um was an evil text from an evil God and
um they rejected the Old Testament
entirely so this uh mortad is basically
spreading marcianite ideology or Marcy
and I like the marcianide sect has been
revived by these liberal Christians
because they're just announcing the Old
Testament and they're saying that well
Jesus came and stopped the Old Testament
and uh this is quite shocking because
even within Catholic or Orthodox
tradition the idea is not that Jesus
came to stop the Old Testament he has a
new covenant but the New Covenant
Covenant doesn't just delete everything
in the previous Covenant the ritual law
is is abolished or is abrogated but that
doesn't mean the entirety of the law is
abrogated in its entirety so that this
is something that is is shocking and
Rasheed like this mortad if he's
actually a Christian he is too
uneducated to know about these kinds of
distinctions and nuances so it's
surprising that he would be brought
forward as some kind of expert or
representative of Christianity stopped
every
yeah no I just wanted to to read one
verse from the Bible in that regard
Matthew 5 17 which says Jesus is
speaking do not think that I have come
to abolish the law or the prophets I
have not come to abolish them but to
fulfill them for I tell you truly until
Heaven and Earth pass away not a single
jot not a stroke of a pen will disappear
from the law until everything be
fulfilled right so this is these are the
words of Jesus he didn't say he didn't
say what they said about the Old
Testament no are you kidding me Jesus
was a God-fearing Jew he did not and
then the sense of his ethnicity he did
not say oh uh no you know just forget
about the Old Testament bye bye that's
happened two three thousand years ago
and just throw it under the bus no he
said not one jot or one Tittle shall
pass away from the law so we see that
actually it is the Muslims that are on
the side of what Jesus says even in
their Bible as opposed to what these
liberal so-called Christians were trying
to defend stopped every he he didn't
Stone the lady who committed adultery
Jake what are your comments here when
you hear him when he came up and he
mentioned the
adulterer the stoning in the top every
he he didn't Stone the lady who
committed adultery to my mind is the
authenticity part of it isn't it true
that this is actually not in the um in
any part of what you have uh because we
don't have a copy of a copy of a copy of
a copy according to uh traditional Bible
scholars people of course call The
Gospel books Matthew Mark Luke and John
well they call the Matthew Mark Luke and
John because we don't know who wrote
these books and there's no point calling
them Sam Fred Jerry and Harry I mean
they're they're written by people we
don't know who they were written by they
are Anonymous you might not think so
because they have the title The Gospel
according to Matthew whoever put that
title on it was an editor later the
followers of Jesus were Aramaic speaking
peasants From Galilee lower class men
who were not educated in fact Peter and
John in Acts chapter 4 verse 13 are
literally said to be illiterate they
couldn't read and write of course not
they were fishermen they didn't go to
school the vast majority of people in
the ancient world never learned to read
let alone write and their native
language was Aramaic these books are
written in Greek by Highly Educated
rhetorically trained writers who are
skilled in Greek compositions of any
original Bible and this is not even in
what we have of any kind of manuscripts
is that correct yeah of course I mean
Scholars even Conservative Christian
Scholars of the Bible have recognized
that the story that he's mentioned which
is supposed to be in the Gospel of John
is a fabrication it's an addition to the
Gospel of John that was not present in
earlier manuscripts and this is not even
just like liberal scholarship of
atheists like Bart Ehrman or anything
like that this is this is from
conservative scholarship in the in the
Bible we have that the uh the stoning of
the woman cotton adultery or the attempt
they were going to elements women in
adultery and a lot of the one I read a
lot of Scholars they debate whether or
not this was an actual
text or this was a later edition added
by a scribe and I was going to ask what
your opinions on this particular matter
were and how to deal with questions
about that how to deal with that that's
a great question and the answer is we we
don't know a whole like what I can tell
you is that the majority scholarly
opinion right now is that the story of
the woman called an adultery that Jesus
said you know he lives without sins let
him cast the first stone that that was
not in the original of John and that
that's why the brackets are there and it
says this is not found in the oldest or
the most reliable manuscripts okay go
ahead and continue Jake I just we wanted
to show this so this is not Muslim just
Conjuring things up lying I mean this is
the scholars now today so consensus yeah
exactly that's right so
um virtually nobody defends The View uh
that that story is actually authentic
and original to the Bible and so for
Rasheed to bring that up and try to make
a theological Point based on that just
shows how ignorant he is of his own uh
you know his own scripture and what his
own Conservative Christian Scholars have
to say about it and it's it's
unfortunate that you know as I said it's
the Muslims that were trying to defend
the Christian scriptures and what they
actually say and these guys are bringing
up you know the ironic part is what
actually is authentic they were calling
fables but then they try to make a
theological Point based on a known
corruption and addition into the
scripture which is a favor they were
fables right so that's the irony there
also logically like logically
would we think that Jesus
peace be upon him was he like against
punishing
um you know punishing adultery or
punishing fornication or punishing other
kinds of deviant sexual behaviors would
he be against that would they what these
liberal Christians want to do is portray
Jesus as in favor of sexual Liberation
like modern sexual Liberation oh Jesus
was fine with like just a free-for-all
of sexual Liberty like is that that's
the way that they're portraying Jesus as
this foil to Islam oh Islam has
regulations against fornication and
adultery and you'll Stone the adulterer
look how barbaric Islam is as opposed to
Jesus which is who was uh you know in
favor of sexual Liberation like is that
really what we should believe this is
ridiculous like this is not what the
actual Christians believe like within uh
the Christian tradition Mission look at
canon law look at what the church
fathers say they are completely in favor
of punishments for adultery punishments
for fornication Augustine you know is on
record uh stating this secretion is on
record stating this and and uh
inscribing it within his canon law so
this is this new interpretation of Jesus
as sexual Liberator it's only found in
the modern period with these liberal
Christians it has no basis in the Bible
it has no even if we did accept this
like uh pericope adultery like within
the Gospel of John like within brackets
oh you know he without sin should cast
the first stone even if we accept that
as authentic that would not
um make Jesus out to be in favor of
sexual Liberation in the way that these
liberal Christians are making him out to
be
foreign
before we conclude just a couple more
points for anybody they can do this on
their own they can um I had to guess uh
Jordan van damn I think it was he was
somebody who was trying to ban Islam
from the Netherlands and what he did
himself was he opened up the Quran and
he took the Bible even being a Christian
and he compared the two he saw okay let
me look at the verses that talk about
combat uh just war and whatnot and he
was seeing like hold on if I'm going to
sit here attack Islam attack Prophet
Muhammad peace it must be upon him what
about Moses Moses when he came back when
they were worshiping the calf in one day
one shot three thousand were killed so
he talks about that he saw actually
there was more Justice and he saw when
he put things in context that hold on
it's not adding up to what these people
what I've been programmed to go ahead
and believe so what can people do when
they hear this now and and even in the
discussion he brought up a chapter nine
verse five all people have to do is just
go read the verse before and after it
right and they'll see that this actually
his arguments fall apart if we wanted to
play that same game uh and be deceitful
and play into this uh Jesus who we love
and Revere uh if this verse right here
is quoted for instance uh and we took
this literally but the Christian I mean
Jake I mean here when the Christian
explains that some of these are
metaphors and whatnot then they'll give
scholarly reference what is this for
instance this one here do not think that
I've come to bring peace to her but of
sort I've not come to being priest but a
sword this one here there's also uh
other verses but now if we want to
insist it means this but then we exclude
all of the Christian tradition and
whatnot that wouldn't be fair I don't
think you would do that uh what do you
think Jake
yeah no I mean uh if you keep reading I
think in that same section I think
that's from the gospel of Matthew
um Jesus makes it explicitly clear right
he is somebody that is coming that
because he's a prophet and somebody are
going to some people are going to
believe what he has to say and other
people are going to reject what he has
to say that he's going to divide
families right he's going to uh separate
Sun from uh mother and father and not
and vice versa and that's because he
knew that there were going to be some
that uh followed his way and others that
rejected him so he's not what some
modern day Christians want to paint him
out to be that he was just liberal you
know hippie I mean they try to make him
like he's a hippie from the the 60s and
70s or something like that and it's it's
certainly not the case right so
um what I think a lot of these people
just haven't even really read their own
Bible or or at the very least have read
and a very surface level fashion they
haven't really deeply thought about what
is being taught in the Bible and what is
being said by Jesus
and that was a part of the discussion we
didn't get into Muslims love for Jesus
is a mighty messenger and the
authenticity of the Bible and other
things that we could the Trinity this is
something that you like to debate this
is something that brought you actually
to Islam the pure monolithism worshiping
God Almighty the creator of law alone
and not his creation that's actually
your story this is what brought you to
Islam submission and surrender to the
one and only one creator of the heavens
and earth uh so let's end with that
we're almost out of time here a couple
more minutes is is this something that
we're we're making up we're doing uh
another uh lying when we say we love and
revered Jesus this is a good talking
point I mean we don't curse him curse
his mother like some people do and and
and call them all sorts of evil names
him and his mother we say peace be upon
him this is something Owen Benjamin for
example he's one example when you saw
like hold on you know he was somebody
who was also talking negatively about
Islam but when he saw these actually was
you and me Daniel remember we were
actually uh talking and sent a message
to him and we reacted to some of his his
uh latest uh comments how he was
actually defending Prophet Muhammad now
and defending Islam so this is not
something we're making up and this is
something that we we have a lot in
common here uh where we differ we get
the elephant out of the room we don't
believe that he ever ever said that he
was God to worship himself or that he
was a literal Son of God but he was a
mighty messenger he called he was a
servant of God he was a prophet of God
just like the Bible actually says so uh
what are you guys comments on that
I think a lot of Christians through
um their own research or they look at
they watch this Patrick but David
podcast they're realizing that they're
they've been duped like they've been
duped into thinking that Muslims are the
enemy that Islam is this kind of satanic
religion and Muslims are just out to
kill Christians I think they're starting
to realize
um they definitely started to realize
that this is all lies like we have been
brainwashed or we've been tricked into
having this negative view of Muslims and
Islam when the reality is that Islam is
the only other religion other than
Christianity to have a positive view of
Jesus other religions are either they're
they're neutral regarding Jesus or they
actually have a negative view of Jesus
but Muslims are Islam is the only other
religion other than the Christianity
that has a positive very positive view
of Jesus and as you said we love him and
respect them and his mother so I think
alhamdulillah Christians are many of
them the ones who are practicing in
religious are waking up and they're
saying that okay I need to really look
more closely at Islam and have a
different attitude towards Muslims what
I want and what I've said in the podcast
and afterwards is it would be great for
Christians to become Muslims but even if
they're not going to become Muslim at
least don't take us as enemies at least
don't look at us as the enemy because
there are bigger enemies of Christianity
and Islam that are attacking both of us
we have to in whatever ways make sense
and we can we have to try to build
Bridges and work together against these
larger enemies these larger forces
that's the message I would have for
Christians who are listening to this
Jake and that was that was the vision of
uh Patrick being David that's why he he
he was talking about working with uh
Muslims to combat the sexualization of
children you know this whole gender
Spectrum all these other things that are
happening and this is what we agree with
we have what bigger fish to try when I
wanted him to see
um and it's hard to do that in one
podcast and what I want
um more Christians to see is that it's
not just about this gender bender stuff
like that is just a the latest
manifestation of these this larger
attack on religion this larger attack on
tradition that you know gender operation
for three-year-olds that's just the the
most Brazen in your face manifestation
or iteration of the problem the problem
has roots that go much deeper into the
past
um we can say over 200 years ago with
this Enlightenment project this
atheistic and Enlightenment
Enlightenment project which was
manifested in the in the ideology of
liberal secularism liberal secularism
that is the attack that is the enemy
that has been attacking uh not only
traditional Christians but also
traditional Jews and Muslims so we have
to recognize that ideology for what it
is for how toxic toxic it is maybe it
has taken uh this kind of extreme attack
on children and and gender operations
for children for Christians to finally
wake up and say oh wow you know there's
a real problem here maybe that's what it
took but now Christians like Patrick
Beth David those who are listening to
this need to reflect that we didn't get
to this position of you know putting uh
kindergarteners on on uh on estrogen or
hormone blockers or whatever we didn't
get to this point without a thousand
steps that preceded it and if you're
going to address the problem you have to
address the roots you have to dress the
roots not the rotten fruit so what is
the root of this problem how can we
address it how can we critique it how
can we save our communities Society
civilization civilization itself from
this Menace
uh Jake uh tell us uh a Muslim is one
who submits his will to the creator of
the heavens and earth so you've been a
Muslim now for about a decade yeah
correct and when you hear this term they
say oh man he's the Antichrist these
these uh Muslims now he he turned
against Christ what do you say to him no
I I think that I am closer than G to
Jesus than I ever was
um and I'll just wrap up this whole
session with one story that I think uh a
lot of Christians out there need to hear
who maybe don't know anything about
Islam I didn't know anything about Islam
I had no idea that Muslims believed in
one and only true God the same creator
that created everything right I had no
idea that they believed that Jesus was
somebody to be loved and respected uh
somebody who was a prophet and messenger
of God who did many miracles who was
born of a virgin all of these things I
never knew right but when I read the
Quran for myself uh with an open mind
and open heart I realized that it was
the truth primarily because of its clear
and unwillingness to compromise on pure
mono is as opposed to what we find in
with all due respect I don't mean this
to hurt Christians but with their
doctrine of Jesus being God uh with
their doctrine of the Trinity Islam has
a much clearer and understandable
doctrine of who God is and also who
Jesus is yes he's someone we love and we
respect and is one of the greatest human
beings ever however we will never
violate tawheed or the idea of pure
monotheism by saying that a man was
actually God and I think that that's
something very important and it relates
to a lot of what we have to say
um when it comes to these other social
issues but as Daniel was pointing out
and and like I was saying earlier
we want to unite and build Bridges with
traditional Christians but what that
means is we want people to go back to
their traditional Roots we want people
to go back to their scriptures and have
values that are in line with their
tradition and scriptures rather than
this secular liberal ideology that as
Daniel said is the result of going away
from scripture that's what it is it was
going away from scripture replacing it
with science or pseudoscience and uh
these vain you know philosophies that
actually are completely opposed to
scripture and Traditional Values they
need to drop that and go back to their
traditional roots and scripture and then
Muslims and Christians can work together
much easier Insha'Allah
thank you both thank you both for being
with us and doing a post analysis of the
discussion or debate of the year
inshallahu
and I thank my guests again Daniel and
Jake and I want to thank Patrick who was
fair and balanced in this discussion
that turned into a debate and as I
opened up in the beginning give an
example of el Amin the trustworthy the
truthful that's who we strive to emulate
so as for us to have integrity to be
honest trustworthy truthful
and when you have people in an industry
like this who is creating you know you
go to the movies and they manufacture
fear so you can understand that you go
there and you see The Exorcist the
Boogeyman and then you come out and
you're like you know you're scared and
your your mother your father will tell
you like you got another fears it's just
it's fake fear it's they they
manufacture this to get you scared
that's what these people do brothers and
sisters
that's what these people do
they end up sucking in money tons of it
so 1.3 billion dollar industry and
they're part of that so their whole life
is about
manufacturing fear lying deceiving and
these are the people even them at the
end of the day if they change their way
we always leave the door open because
God Almighty Allah is the most loving
the most merciful
and as we were leaving and I'll conclude
with this as we're leaving this pbd
podcast I got to see one of the
panelists and I told him I said that in
the few seconds that we spent
as I saw him getting my bag and I'm
leaving and he just happened to be there
in the room and I told him I said look
it starts off with being sincere with
yourself
and then being sincere with your Creator
and asking your creator for guidance
so turn to the one God Almighty and ask
for guidance and many people they don't
do that so then they go down these these
roads and they go down these Avenues of
of spreading corruption in the land and
this is exactly what these individuals
are doing they're not trying to come to
the table to build Bridges and to have
peace with their neighbors they're
spreading fear and like I opened up with
a tweet from someone who went through
the war in Bosnia and they saw what
these hey provocative doors do they end
up splitting neighbor from neighbor and
they end up causing all this friction
anxiety manufacturing fear so now you
fear your Muslim neighbor and this leads
to violence and it's a never-ending
cycle
so with that said let's build these
Bridges let's go ahead and work together
I love this Vision we can get the
elephant out of the room there's some
things that we don't agree upon but I
think we have a much more in common so
let's bring people to the table who can
go ahead and spread this Vision to their
congregants to their communities because
we need more of this the reality is
Christians are not going nowhere Muslims
are not going where the people that are
on this planet they're not going we're
not going anywhere so
we have to learn to live together in
peace and Harmony speak your truth but
at the end of the day speak it in
fairness Injustice in truthfulness don't
lie don't deceive don't cheat as these
people who are spreading this fear
spreading this hate are doing and with
that said guys if you benefited from
this go ahead and like share subscribe
so more people can benefit just like you
did and we'll see you next time
Insha'Allah God willing we start with
peace we end with peace
peace be with you if you like this
episode of the dean show go ahead and
click this video up here or up here for
more and don't forget to like all the
videos so more people can go ahead and
benefit just like you have hit that
notification Bell subscribe we'll see
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with you